[Musique]
l'impératrice chapelier fou et
saint-michel trois artistes et groupes
qui participent au festival électro chic
le festival électro de versailles grand
parc qui a lieu du 15 au 17 mars
des concerts bien sûr sont au programme
mais aussi des ateliers des rendez vous
pour les enfants bonjour mélanie au jour
camille non je propose on plonge dans la
programmation donc du choc du chic ça
c'est le off du festival électro chic
le premier rendez vous c'est un atelier
le samedi 17 mars le matin de 11h à 12h
vous allez pouvoir découvrir des sites
musicaux pour s'amuser avec les sons les
mélodies les voies et même créer votre
propre tubes aux manettes de l'atelier
le groupe électro-pop saint michel
[Musique]
de paille
ainsi qu'une piste ok monsieur paris
m
cette année
et comme les adultes ils pourront aussi
profiter de la musique avec une boum une
boum 2 heures pour danser à londres le
théâtre et centre d'art de vélizy
villacoublay
alors là ça débute à 15h ça se termine à
17h07 aviv entre copains et copines
surtout pas de parents et tout de suite
après un atelier bidouille avec le
circuit blending et pour comprendre le
principe on écoute le divi ludovic
moreau ça fait partie aussi du monde
électro c'est à dire que dans électro il
ya électronique donc il ya tout un
travail ou toute une réflexion sur sur
l'accessoire sur le doubs vienne le sont
parce que c'est des sons qui était à la
base de voile un kiki qui sont pas des
sons d'instruments de musique au sens
classique mais faire de la musique avec
des accessoires industriel revisiter des
tournées et c'est l'association data
glitch qui animera cet atelier où vous
transformerez vos enfants vos jouets en
véritable instrument avec un simple fer
à souder un peu d'imagination
le rendez vous est donné à 17h comme
toujours sur un festival des rendez vous
que nous vous autres que nous vous
donnions ne sont pas exhaustifs pour ne
rien rater
direction le site internet du festival
merci une année on verra plutôt à la
bombe vous atelier alors elle abou ala
bonjour
ouais je sais c'est amusant